oops
so long gay boys
wait a second
hello Internet creatures I'm Dave Rubin
this is the Reuben report it's July 5th
2023 that's right America has celebrated
her
247th birthday I hope you were out there
with the burgers and the dogs and the
fireworks and the beer not the Bud Light
and all the other good stuff because we
still despite everything people have an
awful lot to celebrate in this country
and it is now our job to protect those
things that we should be celebrating
we're going to be talking a bit about
that today and what happens when you do
not protect those things like free
speech and borders etc etc of course as
always we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and on locals if you want to
join us for the post game show do so at
reubenreport.locals.com and Hearty
welcome to all the new members the
community's been growing at a nice pace
so it's good to see everybody over there
before we get to the show real quick I
saw something yesterday today you know I
try not to tweet over the weekends or
the extended holiday weekends and that
kind of stuff every now and again I'm
looking at my phone I admit it I am not
the perfect person so I try not to you
know that much but anyway I saw on
Twitter that there is a website that
will do an AI explanation of your
Twitter feed so literally you just put
in your Twitter handle at Reuben report
for me and then within I don't know
three seconds it basically gives you an
AI report on what you're all about and I
want to read you mine because I thought
it was pretty good but not perfect and
that shows you a little bit of the
danger of what's going on with AI so
this is from Twitter GPT based on a
close examination of Reuben reports
recent tweets it is evident that they
have a strong affinity for American
patriotism and celebrate the country's
history and freedom they frequently
Express support for the United it States
and its values additionally they engage
with political figures such as Elon Musk
David Sachs and Robert F Kennedy Jr
indicating an interest in politics and
current affairs Reuben report often
retweets content related to Thomas Soul
an American Economist and social
theorist this suggests a potential
interest in economics and conservative
ideologies they also retweet posts
critical of affirmative action
indicating a belief in meritocracy and
opposition to race-based policies in
terms of Personality Reuben reports
tweets exhibit a straightforward and
direct communication style they express
their opinions openly and do not shy
away from controversial topics their
sense of humor can be described as
sarcastic and biting often using irony
to make their point based on their
tweets it's difficult to determine Rubin
report's home City however they
frequently engage with individuals from
the United Kingdom such as Douglas
Murray and suffrage gent that's uh
that's my buddy who's on on Friday
suggesting a potential connection or
interest in British politics and culture
considering their political allegiances
Reuben reports tweets indicate a
conservative leaning they express
skepticism towards the Biden
Administration criticized Progressive
Democrats and support conservative
figures and ideas however it's important
to note that this analysis is based
solely on their recent tweets and may
not fully capture their complete
political beliefs if you were going to
get Reuben report a gift you should
consider getting them a copy of the
vision of the anointed
self-congratulation as basis for social
policy by Thomas Soule this book aligns
with their interests in thomasville's
ideas and provide a deeper deeper
exploration of his conservative
perspectives anyway the reason I wanted
to show that to you is that this chat
GPT thing and this AI stuff whether it's
AI video or images or audio it's
happening right in front of our eyes we
haven't talked about it a ton on this
show and we will dive into it more I
want to get a couple Specialists on
Aiden talk about all the cool stuff that
could come from Ai and all the dangerous
stuff you know my love of dystopian
Sci-Fi movies so uh I think this could
probably go either way and most likely
it goes the wrong way but I thought that
was interesting that basically with
machine learning
and chat GPT you can get a pretty good
snapshot that's a pretty solid snapshot
it thinks I'm more interested in British
politics because I had a couple of
British guests on last week the fact
that it didn't say anything about
Florida or couldn't figure out I live in
Miami like that's kind of surprising but
anyway that shows some of like the
positives of this stuff like it really
in no time machines can now spit out
something that's pretty clear but not
perfect and that's sort of the uh the
interesting I would say road that we are
going to have to Traverse uh when it
comes to the future of AI anyway the
theme of today's show is happy July 4th
even though today is July 5th uh you
know this country 247 years old as I
often talk about is the greatest
experiment in humankind the idea that
people from everywhere on Earth with
their foods and traditions and music and
clothes and cultures and all of those
things that they could come to this new
place and this new place could put them
all together not keep them separate
actually become a Melting Pot that would
be based in human freedom and individual
rights and all of these things and it's
still even now despite everything all
the craziness and the political
polarization and everything else it's
still the dream of the world right it's
still the place everyone wants to come
to and nobody's leaving the people that
spend all day long AOC virtually every
Democrat every dingbat on MSNBC they
spend all day long complaining about
this place I went on Twitter yesterday
trying to find like some positive people
on the left saying nice things about
America on July 4th it's basically
impossible mostly it's about all the
horrible things that we've done but
nobody leaves nobody leaves so we are
divided yes and we are at a precarious
moment for sure but that gives us great
opportunity to steer this thing and
hopefully we can steer it back to some
of the principles that the founders were
coming up with say 250 plus years ago
and would I want to contrast that with
is a country that's really struggling
right now if you are paying attention to
mainstream media I know you guys are
wiser than that you're not seeing much
on what's going on in Paris for the last
10 days or so but Paris has been burning
absolutely burning they have let in
thousands hundreds of thousands of
migrants they don't know what these
people are up to they don't know what
their cultures they brought all these
people in they did not integrate them
the way we do in the United States and
they've got major problems and I want to
contrast that with what America is all
about that's what we're doing today let
me talk to you guys about moink box real
quick and then we'll get to it you guys
know that 60 of U.S pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day guys there's a better way I
want to tell you about moink that is Moo
plus oink Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops and salmon fillets
and much more plus he can cancel any
time and as you know I do love cooking
some meat on my big green egg on a
Friday evening Shark Tank host Kevin
O'Leary called moink's bacon the best
bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got moaked keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time and now back to me okay so
yes yesterday
we celebrated the birthday of America
247 years young she's doing all right
despite all the forces always trying to
take her out but I thought a nice way of
kicking off the show today would be a
flashback uh to about 40 years ago 1980
and you know what happened in 1980
Budweiser put out this July 4th
commercial
buds for you
there's no one else who doesn't quite
the way you do
until you see
you you know it isn't only what you say
it's what you do
[Music]
foreign
yeah just for you that distinctively
clean crisp taste that says Budweiser so
that was July 4th 1980 and it's just
American people taking pride and working
smiling poking fun at each other
enjoying themselves out by the grill
doing actual work with other people
pretty pretty good also it seems clear
that they're pitching to a certain type
of person who might drink their product
but you guys know the woke ruin
everything and they have ruined
Budweiser specifically uh Bud Light now
let's Flash Forward to just over the
last couple months uh you know this ad
that Bud Light put out with Dylan
Mulvaney
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us
so I kept hearing about this thing
called March Madness and I thought we
were all just having a hectic month but
it turns out it has something to do with
sports and I'm not sure exactly which
sport but either way it's a cause to
celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay okay so 1980 to 2023 and
we've done this sort of thing before
I've shown you old ads or old things
from The Tonight Show versus what's
going on today but the real question is
how did we go from that to where we're
at right now and where does that put
most of us most of us who don't care for
this nonsense most of us who might be
represented by guys like little known
podcaster Joe Rogan and a little-known
rapper Ice Cube Ice Cube was the guest
on Joe Rogan's podcast a couple days ago
they got into this craziness about Bud
Light and Target going woke and how the
average person like you like me has just
about had enough
the The Pride people are mad at him
because they didn't support Dylan
Mulvaney so they they like kicked it out
you don't win
you know either way at the end of the
day but
um
you know I think about the companies
that own these companies the people that
own these companies and why would they
let a decision like that take the
company down I don't think they thought
it was going to I think this is a
legitimate public outrage one where they
just push too far and people and
you and it wasn't even like a real like
promotion it was a thing they sent a can
to this person is Dylan Mulvaney person
but I don't think it went anywhere else
I think it was just like here this is
for you and you put it on social media
they made some sort of a partnering deal
you know and that was it so why Target
do the same thing well I think that's an
ESG thing that's an ESG thing right and
Target lost billions of dollars too
because people people are sick of this
they're sick of social things like that
that are controversial getting stuffed
into your face and where you have to
accept it yeah and people are like I
don't want to accept it it's just like
I'm just coming here for toilet paper
that's the point it's not that people
are not accepting of different
Lifestyles or often as I say as an adult
you want to dress however you want you
want to marry whoever you want okay most
people are on board that sort of thing
not everybody and by the way everybody's
entitled to their own religious beliefs
and everything else you can't you can't
legislate other people's freedom right
we all deserve the same individual
rights but Rogan's hitting it there at
the end when you walk into Target you're
there to buy something right you want to
buy a toilet I'd like to buy toilet
paper I want to get some beer let's say
I want to get some kids clothes I want
to get a basketball and what else would
I get there a candle that's what I'm at
Target for I don't need to walk in and
be bludgeoned with stuff that will have
kids tucking their genitals so that they
can pretend to be the other gender right
and we know the same thing with Bud
Light and everything else so how has it
affected these companies I mean and the
beauty is that it has affected these
companies not because it was a top-down
decision but the average person just saw
this finally enough of us started
talking about it and then the average
person decided to put their money use
their wallet elsewhere right and what
that does is it makes it so that you
actually have some power this is really
extraordinary stuff now updates on some
of how this has affected these
corporations this is from The Daily Mail
Bud Light is now cheaper than water at
some retailers after the 20 billion
dollar Dylan Mulvaney disaster as some
stores report 50 percent decline in
sales year on year after marketing
gimmick gone wrong so it actually
doesn't matter whether as Joe Rogan said
this was just like a throwaway thing
where they were like okay Dylan Mulvaney
put this up on social media we didn't
put much thought into it or it was a
real corporate decision now actually we
know it was a real corporate decision
because we've played I think a couple
times for you guys some of the videos of
the executives saying why they were
pushing this right why they wanted a
more diverse beer drinking audience and
that they didn't want to be so focused
on Frat Boys they wanted it to be more
enlightened or something like that by
the way the two Executives in charge of
the campaign have been fired so it was
actually specific and targeted not just
a little throwaway thing but that that
sort of uh decide beside the point but
now I'm going to show you how divided
America is on woke verse non-woke and
how they're using this ridiculous
LGBT thing to stoke these divisions
despite the fact that we're no longer in
pride month and thank God can we finally
go back to a little shame a little
old-fashioned shame wouldn't that be a
freaking pleasure but as we know they
want to make it pride summer now but not
in this house I'll tell you that much
we'll get to that in just a sec let me
talk to you guys about route 66. uh how
many of you out there have had the
opportunity to take a travel and
vacation across Mid-America on the
mother Road well running
2400 miles from Chicago to L.A the
iconic Highway enables thousands of
vacationers the opportunity to get their
kicks on Route 66 and tap into the
Nostalgia of a booming time in America's
past however with the construction of
the U.S Interstate freeway system many
of the shops have gone out of business
introducing one of our newest sponsors
the Route 66 revitalization this is a
non-profit organization that was created
to bring awareness to the Forgotten
businesses still surviving along the old
Route 66 Corridor I've driven it many
times and it's a beautiful thing in
addition to Bringing awareness to the
upcoming hundred year anniversary of
this famous Road they are dedicated to
helping kick-start economic recovery and
sustainability for these businesses the
Route 66 revitalization team in
partnership with the California Route 66
Museum located between Vegas and Los
Angeles needs your help this American
treasure nearly closed several times
over the year years however the Museum's
dedicate dedicated volunteers began
paying for operating expenses out of
pocket to keep the doors open with the
help of the Route 66 revitalization and
donors like you the Route 66 Museum
continues to open three days a week free
to the public and the revitalization
team is helping to raise funds for
projects like moving in 1968 historical
Caboose next to the museum to drive more
traffic you can help by sending a
donation through Zell to donations at
Route 66
revitalization.com or make donations
directly to the historic Route 66 museum
at info at CA
route66museum.com and now back to me
okay so
we know that they have jammed all of
these letters together these letters
that have nothing to do with each other
and they keep extending the letters and
more and more people are involved in
this and it has nothing to do with
reality another thing that they are
doing is pointing all of this at
children right and they're always
telling us that they're not your
children they're our children well just
this weekend the elderly gentleman
pretending to be President Joe Biden was
at a July 4th celebration they let him
out of the crypt for a couple hours and
once again he went after your children
children are the kite strings they're
not somebody else's shoes they're all
our children are the kite strings that
lift our national Ambitions Aloft and
you hold those strings you hold those
strings
right meaningless dribble as always no
Joe Biden is not my son Joe uh Hunter
Biden is not my son and my kids are not
your kids he's also slurring through it
it's all the usual stuff right but the
thing is these things they come
from people like Joe Biden they come
from our corporations and then they leak
into everything this is why bottom up is
good right when you boycott things
because you're like oh I don't like
these corporations I don't like what
these people are doing the people that
are making these movies I don't like
this I'm not going to give them my money
that's a beautiful thing because it
gives power to you they like it the
other way they like to say oh your
children are our children you will buy
these products it's a top-down thing we
like to do it the other way but it
starts with Biden it starts with these
corporations and then it leaks into
everything uh much like it has leaked
into almost all of our religious
institutions as well I saw this video
over the weekend this is wild uh from
some woke this is a woke church I mean
this this feels like a waiting for
guffman parody or or Best in Show parity
but this is real look what's going on at
the woke churches of America
I don't think that there is a safe space
for queer people in our churches
the church in America and the world we
don't know what to do with queer folks
the church has failed a lot of people
[Applause]
I will go to church and every time we
want to pray the gay away I'm Drew my
pronouns are they and he I'm just
queering Church
[Music]
so it's coming after everything you know
it's it's interesting as I always say
like if you have certain religious
beliefs you have certain beliefs when it
comes to marriage or anything else as
long as you're not legislating those
beliefs I I am perfectly able to respect
your beliefs and I believe in Live and
Let Live to the same extent that I would
not force a synagogue or a church or a
mosque there aren't a lot of mosques
that do gay weddings I wouldn't Force
any of them to have my beliefs but you
can see how wokeism destroys anything do
you think there is any chance that once
this woke nonsense which by the way it's
not just about okay we just want two
dudes to get married so could you marry
us it becomes a completely holistic
political ideology do you think once
it's in these churches once they're
hanging that flag much like we hang that
flag at the White House that it's not
going to affect every other thing that
the church is trying to teach now you
may not be part of a church you may not
like those ideas but they're entitled to
have those ideas right they are entitled
to have those ideas the wokesters are
entitled to have their ideas the problem
is we're forcing all of these things
together and then it leaks as I said
it's in politics it's in our
corporations it's in our religious
institutions and of course what's it in
well it's in all of our movies and our
television and the rest of the stuff
that we show once again our kids this is
really wild you guys know that in a
couple weeks if you haven't seen it it's
all over online everywhere the Barbie
movie is coming out uh Mary Margaret
olahan uh tweeted this out uh Barbie
release on July 21st there's a ton of
hype around this movie what you may have
missed it includes a biologically male
actor who identifies as a woman playing
a female doctor and there's the
biological male
who plays a female in the movie who not
plays a female who is a female is quote
unquote is a female in the movie
um the point of all of this guys it I
don't have a problem with the Trans
person being an actor or anything else
as you know or not even a trans person
you want to dress up like a chick and go
get a gig like you want to be a plumber
that would be funny like you you you
know you got like a you got a clogged
toilet you call the plumber and then
like you know like a dude in a dress
shows up like I'll fix your toilet
um
I don't have a problem with any of that
but the point is Barbie is made for
children now I get it everyone's stuck
in like some weird adolescent thing so
it'll be mostly 35 year olds going to
see this thing but they are
intentionally trying there's a gajillion
girls out there who would love to be in
the Barbie movie as a girl so why do
they go out of their way to have a
biological boy play a girl who's
supposed to be completely a girl in the
Barbie movie unless they're trying to
confuse kids unless they want some kid
to realize something's a little weird
about that some eight-year-old kid is
going to watch the Barbie movie be like
something's a little odd there and then
bring that up with their parents and
then their parents have to explain that
to them when all they wanted to do was
get two hours of Peace on a Saturday
afternoon by taking them to our movies
so you get you guys get it right not
only are institutions and industries
getting flooded with a bunch of this
woke nonsense but many many almost all
of the machine heads that's a good one
right the machine heads the people who
are out there doing what I do but doing
it for the machine just repeating the
nonsense over and over we're going to
call them machine heads for now on what
are they doing they are constantly
stoking division around all of this so
check this out this is over on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC this is noted racist Joy Reed and
she is not happy with what's going on
right here in the Free State of Florida
over the course of the past year the
United States of America has become an
increasingly less safe place for the
lgbtq community just weeks ago the Human
Rights Campaign for the first time
declared a national state of emergency
for lgbtq Americans a report from the
Anti-Defamation League and glad says
there's been more than more than 350
incidents of anti-lgbtq harassment
vandalism or assault in the U.S since
last year not to mention a record number
of anti-lgbtq bills have been introduced
in republican-controlled state houses
across the country many of which have
become law and Ground Zero for this
anti-lgbtq movement is Florida led by
its Governor Ron DeSantis who's been
seemingly who seemingly made it his
entire goal to ban everything from drag
shows to even just talking about
sexuality in schools this of course is
happening in the same state where just
seven years ago the deadliest attack on
the lgbtq community in modern history
took place when a gunman killed 49
people and injured 53 others at Pulse
Nightclub in Orlando
guys let me be clear Florida is
absolutely fine for gay people there is
no hate for gay people people just don't
Chuck things that gave people out
that was messed up that was really
messed up
I just want to just go through what she
uh
I said to Phoenix during the break
during the as we were playing that clip
I was like throw something at me he
turns about you throw it at him like uh
you were afraid you were gonna miss me
even though you're only two feet away
from me that's that's Brock's a fine
athlete okay there's no state of
emergency for gay people this is the
most idiotic thing I've ever seen also
350 anti-gay incidences now this is
someone walking down the street and
being like you I don't like you in 11
months that's actually not that many
we're a giant country of 350 million
people and there are no anti-lgbt bills
there aren't there are bills about what
you are allowed to do in front of
children if you are an adult male
wearing a dog costume and some crazy
get tied up your nuts in some weird
thing could you just not do that in
public in front of somebody else's kids
that's what's going on that's what we're
making illegal here I know plenty of gay
people in Florida Penny of gay people
are still moving here and they are
living their lives like everyone else
because as I often say much like black
people gay people just like safe cities
and flourishing economies and nice
weather and good neighbors and things of
that nature but more and more people are
picking up on it right that's why more
and more people are tuning out of uh of
MSNBC and more and more people are
realizing that these letters have
nothing to do with each other I want to
show you this this is Andrew Tate
talking about how
LGBT makes absolutely no sense
lgbtq they package it all together and I
would argue that G and T are very
different things a gay man and someone
who's chopped the dick off are very
different things so they package it all
together so now cut the spectrum of your
enemy is so large you have people who
are complete fully this way if you're
people who we accept that are normal in
society we have no problem with gay
people and they put it all together
you're an enemy of all these people and
they complicate the argument and they
mix it all together and I drew bigot and
really you just want your kids to be
left alone
yeah yeah that's right and that's what
most people have come around to again
you don't have to love gay people you
should you should like people based on
their behaviors and you know whatever
you don't have to right again you can
have your own religious beliefs you
can't legislate those beliefs but he got
it right there they have widened the
spectrum of these things because the
gays and the lesbians it was all taken
care of you got marriage no law is
discriminating against everybody you got
equality but the activists could not
give it up because they need division
the non-profits need division Joy read
needs division all of these people need
that division because without the
division you might just go ahead and
live your life and be happy and not give
them money and not give them attention
and they don't deserve either one of
those things so this is exactly why
there is so much division right now
because woke the most it is the most
dangerous idea apology that we have had
in America in the last 50 years it's
communism on steroids right it's
collectivism with a dash of racism and
gender confusion and once you are
whittled down to your inherent
differences uh you are going to have a
very difficult Society to operate in
because especially in America where
we've welcomed everybody so what other
uh Western nation is struggling right
now because obviously it's not us well
there are major like crazy crazy riots
happening in Paris for the last week or
so you're probably not seeing this on
CNN you're probably not seeing this on
MSNBC actually Brock could you go and
just scan MSNBC and CNN's Twitter feed
for the last like three days see how
many times they mentioned what's going
on in Paris or put up videos I'm just
curious but I want to read a bit about
what's going on in France right now from
the daily wire huge riots have escalated
all over France in the wake of a police
shooting of a 17 year old Algerian
Muslim prompting authorities to deploy
40 000 police on the streets of major
cities including Paris Thursday night
the incident which sparked the rioting
occurred Tuesday when a police officer
shot and killed nahil M during a traffic
stop near nantir west of Paris according
to Reuters the teenager was driving in
the bus lane during a traffic jam when
he was pulled over to stop but refused
to provide a license and then tried to
drive away the officer shot him in the
left arm and chest according to the
nantir public prosecutor who added that
the officer feared that the teenager
would start a car chase and injure
others police said nahil M had been
known to ignore traffic stops before he
had to be stopped but obviously the
officer didn't want to kill the driver
the police officer's attorney stated
riots were reported from Paris where a
dozen buses were burned and store
windows were smashed along the Route all
the way to robay in the north at
Marseille in the South as well as rains
and London in a Paris suburb a shopping
mall was burned in Marseille the
country's largest library was burned the
headquarters of the Paris 2024 Olympics
in San Santini were set on fire the
state must be firm in its response
darmanian stated he also said 875 people
were arrested on Thursday night the
writing has escalated
France is 24 France 24's International
Affairs editor Angela diffley said it
appears to be morphing into something
closer to General rioting we saw a huge
amount of looting and pillaging of
ordinary businesses and some high-end
shops okay so now you have a little bit
of backdrop on what happened but what
really is going on is something very
similar to what happened in the United
States in the wake of the George Floyd
uh incident which is that these people
use a police incident for General Mayhem
and for destruction of all that is good
and decent and France has a particular
uh problem with this because of the
amount of immigration that they LED in
the hundreds of thousands of people from
North Africa and Middle East countries
and everything else and then they did
not integrate them properly into their
society here's about a minute long
compilation of some of the absolute
Mayhem I mean this is this is wild what
is going on in Paris right now
what
come on
foreign
[Music]
that's not a rack that's not Libya that
is Paris that is Paris France which
which once was the the cultural center
of the world they let in hundreds of
thousands of immigrants I can't say
illegal immigrants in their case
although some of them did come illegally
but they had open borders in essence
over the last decade they LED in all of
these people they did not integrate them
properly they the state starts giving
them things but of course it's never
enough that puts them at odds with the
average uh French taxpayer who is now
footing the bill for people that they
have nothing in common with culturally
they have different views on women let's
say and gays and other minorities and
other religions etc etc and it is just
an excuse look I'm not going to sit here
pretending that I'm an expert in
politics in France but the theme the
theme that there is a certain set of
people who want open borders who want
Mayhem and are using this combined with
the woke thing which is why I could I
would connect this with the George far
right because it looks the same right
like cities burning things exploding
looting and destroying you know and
they're never taking eggs they're always
taking televisions I guess they're
eating televisions right because AOC
said it's that these people are hungry
mostly but this is pretty disturbing uh
this is in the Paris Square it's the
center of Paris France uh here are uh
well this is dozens if not hundreds of
people waving the Algerian flag
someone
so when you see videos
from our Southern border when you see
Robert F Kennedy Jr out there standing
there in the middle of the night
watching hundreds of people from all
sorts of different countries and
remember he listed all the countries
from people you know people think oh
it's just Mexicans coming that wouldn't
be just and right either way we should
have a border but it's people from all
over the world coming here and then you
wonder well where are these people going
what are they doing what do they believe
are they going to start doing some of
this stuff like is that so crazy what's
happening in Paris does that not seem
like something that could just explode
in New York City like that is does that
not seem like something that could
happen in Los Angeles just like that
it won't happen in Florida it won't
happen in the places that will protect
themselves Texas is trying to do the
best they can as a border state right
but these things are connected Mass
immigration and globalism and and the
fact that there are differences between
cultures there are differences between
religions and there are differences
between the way people behave and if you
do not Step Up for your own country if
you will not look at America that's why
the reason I was trying to do the show
the way we did it today is because I'm
watching yesterday while we here we're
celebrating July 4th and it was our
first July 4th but the boys and we had
them in you know an American flag
outfits and everything and celebrating
fireworks last night and Clyde's going
crazy you know dogs go crazy with the
fireworks and I was just thinking like
how much I love this country and just
all the stuff that you were thinking
right but there's a huge amount of
people here that don't think that and
they want more and more of this chaos
and they want more and more of these
people so France now has a major major
problem because this is now in their
country and they better figure out a way
to deal with it and the way we can deal
with it here is believing in nationalism
believing in borders and things like
that something that France forgot a long
time ago I want to give you some info
from statista on France and migration
France net migration rate from 1950 to
2023 United Nation projections are also
included through the year 2100. the
current net migration rate for France in
2023 is 0.963 per 1000 population a nine
percent increase from 2022. the net
migration rate for France in 2022 was
0.883 per thousand population a 9.96
increase from 2021. the net migration
rate for France in 2021 was 0.803 per
thousand population an 11 increase from
2020. the net migration rate for France
in 2020 was 0.723 per thousand
population
12.44 increase from 2019 so they are
letting in all of those people
and then the question is okay are the
intentions good when they open up orders
you can just ask Angela Merkel right
what did Angela Merkel do at the height
of the Syrian War what did she do she
basically opened the borders of Germany
about a million people came into Germany
she had no idea what their beliefs were
Germany has a history of having problems
uh with minorities religious minorities
and everything else now you bring in a
whole bunch of people and then what
happens they don't all get along they're
they're a drain on the system and then
people start getting angry at each other
they behave differently they they have
different beliefs towards women etc etc
so in France if you import a bunch of
non-people into France then France will
eventually not look like France anymore
we have a bit more on what's going on
there this is from the daily wire the
United Nations jumped into the
discussion about riots in France
catalyzed by the death of a Muslim
teenager shot by police as a U.N
spokeswoman call accused French law
enforcement of racism we are concerned
by the killing of a 17 year old of North
African descent by police in France on
Tuesday U.N human rights office
spokeswoman Ravina shamdasani said we
note that an investigation has been
launched into alleged voluntary homicide
this is a moment for the country to
seriously address the Deep issues of
racism and discrimination in law
enforcement we also emphasize the
importance of peaceful assembly
shamdasians continued we call on the
authorities to to ensure use of force by
police to address violent elements and
demonstrations always respects the
principles of legality necessity
proportionality non-discrimination
precaution and accountability any
allegations of disproportionate use of
force must be swiftly investigated let
me let me just say that the United
Nations is a sack of stinky that's
all it is it is a globalist organization
designed to destroy Western countries
the people of France right now if you're
watching this in Fran and you're in
France I want to know you you've got an
ally in me and many good Americans you
do not have to listen to the United
Nations those people who are burning
down your cities and blowing up uh car
bombs and hijacking buses and driving
them through uh the city and all of that
stuff the police have in my estimation
the police have every right to shoot
them the police and you as a country
have every right to deport every single
one of them yesterday that is how a sane
society would operate you do the fact
that the United Nations as Paris is
burning down is accusing the French
people the French people who let in the
hundreds of thousands of immigrants in
the first place they let in hundreds of
thousands of people of North Africa did
they do that in the name of racism now
it was misguided and it was stupid but
they did it so were they being racist
when they did it so every nation has an
absolute duty to defend itself and
France has to decide how they're going
to go ahead and defend themselves and
and when this comes more to America
which it will when it spreads to England
when it continues in Germany all of
these countries have to decide what they
want but they should not be taking cues
from the United Nations and the world
economic forum and the rest of it but
now I want to show you how subtly this
stuff gets imported into the United
States because as I've mentioned a
couple times what we have done in the
United States better than any nation in
the history of the world is take
everybody we said everybody you're tired
you're poor and you're huddled masses
hey come here work hard we'll do our
best to make sure that everyone has an
even playing ground and see what happens
and generation after generation it got
better for everybody right you watching
this right now your life is better than
your grandparents I know it right my
life is better than my grandparents life
that is the Beauty and the promise of
America it's tenuous at best right now
but that has been how this has worked
for our 247 years and the reason for
that was we did not always Whittle
people down to their differences you are
this color think like this you are this
sexuality think like this but the modern
left the wokesters that have completely
taken over the Democratic party that's
all they see people as and I want to
give you the most perfect example of
that so Jen saki who is just an absolute
propagandist liar working at the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC uh here she is talking about
what's been going on with some of the
gender related stuff and we remember a
couple weeks ago was it maybe two weeks
ago we showed you how in Glendale in
California that Muslim parents and
Armenians and this has been happening
all over the place by the way this was
happening in Detroit as well uh where
there's a big Muslim population that
parents are just saying you know enough
of this crazy trans ideology we are
protesting against it listen to the way
jensaki frames parents who just don't
want their children sexualized in this
case she's talking about Muslims uh how
she frames them against the trans
Community because this is what they do
with everything you are a group not an
individual
So lately I've been noticing the
re-emergence of a very old GOP Playbook
that Harkens back to president Richard
Nixon's Infamous southern strategy
during his campaign for president in
1968 the Republican Party made a
concerted effort to reach white
Southerners who used to vote for
Democrats by playing to their fears of
African Americans and the civil rights
movement and it worked by pitting one
group of Americans against another the
GOP successfully managed to split off
Southern whites from the Democratic
party now decades later the right wing
is Reviving that same Playbook this time
with Muslim Americans and trans people
hear me out here the GOP is trying to
recruit Muslim Americans a community
that makes up less than two percent of
the US population against another tiny
marginalized group of Americans
transgender people guys it's not the
Muslim parents who don't want their kids
sexualize it that are coming up with
this idea that's not coming from their
own brains they don't have capacity to
think they don't have a capacity to
protect their children and everything
else it's that racist bigoted GOP who
has tricked Muslim parents into hating
the trans people
if you know someone that watches MSNBC
you must remove them from your life I
don't know what if someone if I knew
somebody that I watch MSN where do you
get oh I watch MSNBC I can't talk to you
anymore I'm sorry we have to start
disconnecting from these people all
together okay take them out of the will
they cannot come to dinner anymore you
know they're not coming over for the
barbecue these people are insane
and it's so bigoted you know this is
what the soft bigotry of low
expectations is she thinks that the
average Muslim is not allowed to think
for themselves they're not allowed to
make a choice about their children
they're not allowed to make a choice
about what parental rights are what
school choices what love for America is
if you dare vote Republican it's
actually because you hate trans people
God
awful bile Wench but it continues
speaking of vile wenches Jamel Hill she
used to work at UH ESPN she got booted
from ESPN then where'd she go she went
over to Spotify right and she got booted
for Spotify because they wouldn't pay
her 100 million dollars so she called
them racist anyway uh you'll love this
one from the New York Post Jamel Hill
accuses Asians of carrying the water for
white supremacy for backing affirmative
action decision yes so here you go now
it's the Asian's fault those freaking
Asians who just wanted to be treated
equally and not to have to have scores a
gajillion times better to get into the
same school as a black kid those
freaking Asians carrying water for the
white supremacists
mirror lady get a mirror you're the
racist you're the racist and I've said
this before but you know I saw Jamel
Hill once at the LAX airport and she was
with Michael Jordan not basketball
Superstar Michael Jordan I'm talking
about Michael Jordan the actor and she
was wearing shoes these furry shoes that
these things must have cost five
thousand bucks easily like you could
just like they were Money shoes so this
woman is not oppressed she's a racist
and a big hit and a fool now this one
actually depresses me and speaking of
Michael Jordan I want to shift this to
Charles Barkley for a minute this is
this Charles Barkley I loved him as a
basketball player
and as a broadcaster for the last 20
years he has been one of the funniest
most outspoken interesting like he's
he's a he's important culturally and
every now and again you miss one Chuck
and I think you missed one here uh this
is from the hill
in my will I am leaving Auburn five
million dollars basketball legend
Charles Barkley said I'm going to change
it to be just for scholarships for black
students that's just my way of trying to
make sure Auburn stays diverse I mean
this is so disappointing and this this
constant move for diversity what
percentage of the NBA is black it's over
90 right yeah it's something like 98 it
doesn't even matter should that should
we Whittle it down so that it should be
perfectly diverse because I think
America's 70 white still something like
that should we have 70 percent white
players in the NBA this this focus on
diversity and skin color is so dangerous
so Barkley who who's so out you know
he's been anti-woke before and he gets
so much of this stuff right you may
remember that commercial from around
1992 I'm not a role model right he's
saying I'm just an athlete I'm not a
role model he got a lot of for it
way back when but it's like you missed
one here man because first off if you
also think it's so important I have no
idea how much money you make Barkley I
think you just signed to deal with CNN
right so like the guys probably got 50
million bucks why are you waiting why
wait hopefully Barkley hopefully they
live another 40 plus years I'm guessing
he's probably about 55 60. hopefully you
live in another 40 years why not throw
that 5 million in now you think in 40
years you're 5 million to get more black
people at Auburn is going to have any
meaning or make any sense or anything
else will that help us get past racism
you just missed one here Chuck I love
you I you know it would have been nice
if you would won the 93 finals tough to
stop Jordan at the peak anyway it
continues uh because you know the big
story obviously last week was about what
Chuck was just talking about which was
that the Supreme Court reversed the
affirmative action in college admissions
admissions decision well now multiple
universities and most of this was
focused on Harvard Harvard was the most
glaring example of oh you're an Asian
with Straight A's perfect SATs you speak
five languages you work hard we can't
find anything wrong with you sorry we're
moving you out because we want to
elevate somebody else well now Harvard
post this decision has announced that
they are figuring out ways to work
around this and make sure that diversity
will still be at that apex of the
hierarchy here is Harvard
president-elect Claudine gay of course
her last name is gay it's just
uh talking about their commitment to
diversity
the Supreme Court's decision on College
and University admissions will change
how we pursue the educational benefits
of diversity but our commitment to that
work remains steadfast it's essential to
who we are and the mission that we are
here to advance guys their commitment to
the thing that the Supreme Court just
said was illegal steadfast okay they are
going to figure out other ways to be
racist that's what they're telling you
and as I've said many times I would
never hire someone from Harvard at this
point I'm not interested in hiring
anyone from an Ivy League school I would
be more inclined when we get resumes to
hire somebody who's dropped out of
school or who never went to school who
had some world you know some worldly uh
experience or worked in a shop for a
while or literally anything else did an
apprenticeship an internship it does not
matter I genuinely genuinely mean that
but this this desire to keep a certain
set of people oppressed is is incredible
and there may be no better example of
this this is Chef kiss beautiful tweet
from Charlie Kirk
Obama's complained about being black
oppressed from a luxury yacht in the
Greek Islands after affirmative action
overturned by Supreme Court look at that
fancy yacht I have never been on a yacht
of that nature Connor have you ever
Phoenix ever been on a brock never been
on a oh
no Brock has been on the open that's
funny Brock's been on the Obamas yeah
we'll find out more about that but
that's it right there right this guy who
now is worth hundreds of millions of
dollars who was a community organizer
somehow becomes president of the United
States hope and change and obviously all
failed which is why we get his VP as the
president now and all the rest of that I
have 30 acre estate on the water
Martha's Vineyard climate change don't
worry about that and he's tweeting about
oppression for black people on the yacht
now I'd like to transition to sanity
because you know we like to tie these
things up in the same way so that you
can go about the rest of your day in a
functional manner right can't just show
you crap all day then send you out there
you got a job to do and people to be
around and I'm not trying to make you
crazier here's some sanity for you this
is uh the legendary by the way who just
turned 93 years young just a few days
ago I think on June 27th if I'm not
mistaken Thomas Seoul who actually still
technically is at Stanford and when he
was at Stanford for the majority of his
career Stanford was a somewhat
functional University but this is Thomas
sold about a decade or so ago uh
wrecking absolutely wrecking affirmative
action with Tucker Carlson I think you
often hear people say well affirmative
action may be unfair but it's helped a
lot of people you buy that
it may have helped some people but on
net balance I don't believe it has
there's a marvelous study done uh
showing that when they banned
affirmative action in California uh
University of California system uh
blacks began to uh graduate at a much
higher rate than before graduate with
much higher grade point average
graduated in subjects like math and
Engineering to a far greater extent than
before because now the students went to
those particular parts of the University
system that fitted their particular
academic preparation and they graduated
before you know you could flunk out of
Berkeley or UCLA which does you no good
now you can graduate from Davis or Santa
Cruz and go on to a career
isn't that something if you put people
at schools that they should be in that
match up with their skills with their
work ethic with what the sum totality of
what they are at that ripe age 16-17 and
you put them in a school that can help
that flourish you don't just Elevate
them to a school that can't help them
flourish just because of the color of
their skin that they actually will do
better in life isn't that something and
if you do that you also don't have to
discriminate against those pesky Asians
and white people who work real hard by
the way I'm being informed right now
this is very exciting Barack Obama was
on that yacht in the Greek Islands with
Tom Hanks noted white supremacist Tom
tanks uh it continues let me throw one
more time a soul at you because we
talked about multiculturalism today
what's happening in Paris has nothing to
do with the shooting of this one kid
this is a failure of multiculturalism a
failure to bring in all of these people
say there are no differences between
anyone no idea no culture is better than
any other or anything else here's Thomas
Soul again this is a decade plus back
destroying multiculturalism once again
with Tucker Carlson
multiculturalism has not only taken root
in schools I think it is uncritically
accepted by a lot of Americans haven't
thought it through in this book you you
assaulted head on you describe it as a
barrier to progress and a lot of other
things explain why multiculturalism if
you would is bad
I guess it starts from a false premise
which is that there's something uh that
all that all cultures are equal and some
undefinable sense which has never been
the case I mean some cultures are better
at some things worse than other things
uh and at particular times in history uh
one group's culture may be ascendant and
another time in other groups but what
you almost never see is what they assume
is a norm namely all groups performing
pretty much the same in all kinds of
fields across the board that you you can
go through centuries of History without
finding a single example of that you you
say that that assumption in fact holds
different groups down you write quote
multiculturalism like the caste system
paints people into the corner where they
happen to have been born but at least
the caste system doesn't claim to
benefit those at the bottom
absolutely so when the multiculturalists
say for example that the schools should
not try to uh uh make black students
speak standard English uh the difference
between speaking Standard English and
not speaking Standard English can be
huge in terms of your job your careers
and all sorts of other things
a legend a National Treasure and we are
we are hoping I cannot promise it at 93
years old we are hoping to get one more
interview with him we've been going back
and forth for quite some time there's
some logistical stuff but we're working
on that but the basic idea there that
not all cultures are the same there is a
difference between Algerian culture the
nation of the people who come from the
nation of Algeria and the people who
live in the nation of France these
things are different
sometimes this country is better at this
and this country is better at this this
country might be better more for human
rights this country might be better it
does not matter but the point is they're
not all the same and we have whittled
our modern left and all of our
institutions have whittled everything
down to we are all the same and we are
not all the same and not all ideas are
the same and there is one thing that can
get us out of this pit and that is
American exceptionalism it is American
culturalism the idea that this country
is great that our ancestors paid an
incredible price so that that we could
live in this extraordinary freedom but
we damn well better protect it and soon
otherwise what is happening on the
streets of Paris will happen on the
streets of our major cities we've
already been through a mini version of
that during the summer of love in 2020
right we've already been there so what
we must start thinking about ourselves
is not that we are African Americans or
gay Americans or MSNBC viewing Americans
we must just be Americans and to end
this show with a nice little bow I offer
you one of the best boxers in the
history of boxing Floyd Mayweather who
was from the streets of Detroit not an
easy place to grow up with his view on
what it is to be an American
another African-American I'm an American
I was born on American soil
but I did go back to the motherland and
I love it and made Millions going back
to the motherland but I was born
in America when the Europeans came to
the Native Americans what they like to
call them Native Americans but the
Indians land we don't call them European
Americans so
I don't want to be called an
African-American I'm an American
I'm saying you can call me a black
American but I'm an American when I
compete in the Olympics they didn't say
fighting uh African-American they said
uh that American that's fighting out of
the Red Corner or out the blue corner I
love America
I love this country
I love America I love this country I
love doing this program and I love you
fine people we got a post game show for
you in just moments
reubenreport.locals.com oh and I like
this cold close today and we will see
everybody else tomorrow
well and and the ones that didn't vote
for your bills but run on them
lose your president thank you thank you
thank you very much
thank you thank you
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here
um we'll have reaction and Analysis to
everything we just heard
[Music]